- [Interviewer] All right, Princess, what,
where are you from originally?
- [Princess] I'm from Florida.
- [Interviewer] Florida and
tell me about your childhood.
You grew up with one parents?
- My mom and a stepdad.
- [Interviewer] Okay, and
how was your childhood?
Fairly normal?
- Yeah, it was great.
- [Interviewer] It was great?
- Like a fairy tale.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
How'd you end up down here?
- Because I love drugs
- [Interviewer] Because you love drugs.
You're not the only one.
(everyone laughs)
Which drug is your favorite?
- Heroin and crack.
- [Interviewer] Heroin and crack.
And what age did you
get introduced to this?
- I've been doing heroin
maybe like five years.
I smoking crack maybe two years?
- [Interviewer] And how are old you now?
- 25.
- [Interviewer] And you're
actually not on the street.
You're staying at the hotel.
- Well, I'm on the street,
but my friend broke his leg
so I'm just taking care of him.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see, so you are
generally on the street.
And then what do you
do for money out here?
- I work the street.
- [Interviewer] You
date guys on the street?
That's a sometimes dangerous job, right?
- Very.
- [Interviewer] I'm sure
you've seen some crazy stuff.
- Oh yeah, Probably anything you could
probably imagine has happened to me.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] Give me a story or two.
I've heard some crazy ones already.
- I've been kidnapped.
I've been raped.
I've been,
everything.
- [Interviewer] Kidnapped?
Where'd he take you?
- Well in his car,
And then he took me to like this sex hotel
and then it was real fucked up
and take to a hotel and I was
gone maybe like three days.
- [Interviewer] You were
gone for three days.
You're still in contact with your family?
- [Princess] Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] and they
know you're out here?
- [Princess] Uh huh, Yeah.
I'm completely honest and open with them.
A hundred percent.
- [Interviewer] That's unusual.
A lot of people are hiding
things from their family.
And what do they say?
- [Princess] Everyday they begged me
to come home or go to rehab.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever been clean?
- [Princess] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How did you get clean?
- [Princess] one time I did it on my own.
And a couple of times I went to detox.
One time my mom did it with me.
- [Interviewer] so your
mom is a user as well?
- [Princess] No, no, no.
She's just like laid in bed with me
until I detox out the heroin.
- [Interviewer] Oh, that's nice.
How difficult was that?
- [Princess] You're dying.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
it's gotta be so tough.
- [Princess] It's the
worst thing in the world.
- [Interviewer] How
long did it take for you
to finally got free of it?
- [Princess] So like, I feel
like you're like as sick
for however long.
At one time I got clean in jail.
However long you use it for
you're like majorly sick
like dying for like, Oh, week or two.
The thing you still have the,
- [Interviewer] Relapse
- [Princess] The goosebumps,
the chills of your spine
just to feel normal.
- [Interviewer] It's usually
something that triggers it.
Like some stressful events like that.
- no
- [Interviewer] No? you
just, you just go back
- Just the sick feeling
or how good it feels
- [Interviewer] When the
attractive young female
like you decides to date
guys for money to pay for her
poor habits
- Habits
- [Interviewer] Okay. What
goes through your head
when you first first decided to do that?
Is it just like, you're just so jonesing
for a fix that you just
can't think straight?
- Yeah. You just really don't care.
- [Interviewer] You just don't care.
- No. It's the fastest,
easiest way to get money.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, for a girl like you.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You can
recycle all week long and
you won't make what you make in a minute.
Becomes an easy decision.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And the
guys are generally okay?
- Most of the clients,
most of them are cool.
Yeah. Most of them are cool.
- [Interviewer] White, Hispanic, Black?
- Well, I normally don't date black guys
unless they're really old
because they'll either like
try to be pimps or playing
games or, you know,
and I'm not saying it's
just like it all people
but you know what I mean?
It's mostly Mexicans
- [Interviewer] Mostly Mexican.
And what do you charge for?
- My minimum is 40 bucks out here.
- [Interviewer] So you wear
protection and all that stuff?
- Oh yeah.
When I first came out here
I was doing Backpage on the internet.
I was getting 200 an hour.
I was in Burbank and all those ways
and I was making bank like that.
And I had my sugar daddy
but he decided to put his
hands on me for the first time.
So I left him.
He was a multimillionaire,
but he still calls me
to this day and I was still won't answer.
- [Interviewer] Oh yeah?
Because he got violent?
- [Princess] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Well, thank
you so much for talking to me.
- [Princess] No problem
- [Interviewer] Good luck
with everything out there.
- [Princess] Thank you.